Frank has an encyclopedic knowledge I
would say of all things concerning the
present state of superconducting qubits
and their progress towards systems but
tonight he will focus on one point
variational algorithms and it's I'm
blocking my own screen and quantum
computer co.design please Frank thank
you so this is a bit of an adaptation of
a kind of an adjustment of the title I'd
put into the program but it's following
the same ideas of the abstract so thanks
a lot for inviting me
Florida's also during this week and we
had experimental days and more
mathematical days and probably today can
help us having with the talks of
Aleksandra and me to have a bridge off
you know theoretical physics that
touches both now this is my group and as
you see on the Left we are working on
various projects on gate based quantum
computing on quantum annealing and on
quantum control and the talk is a little
bit motivated by what happens if people
who are working on these different
things are in the same building talk to
each other and try to discover parallels
between their works which may provoke
some thoughts also you clearly see this
photograph on the right is pretty old
because we are not properly socially
distancing so I want to first kind of
motivate why Co designing so why
designing hardware and algorithm
together is something we should still do
it think about when I say this leads to
not quite universal quantum computers I
mean devices that's typically in the
mathematical sense can be universal but
where the cost of embedding
a certain algorithm or certain
programming paradigm is very asymmetric
so there some things you would not like
to do on this why we should still think
about this even though there is a big
trend nowadays also driven by
needs to offer like standardized
platforms and do all processors I will
give you two examples from papers of
ours which that can do one is a
architecture had no wires cross for a
calculation for something called
variational set energy and I will
explain you why you should care about
this concept I will then show a new on
paper where I want to discuss how you
can make the cue AOA algorithm with only
single qubit controls co.design then I
will make an excursion it's something we
are very proud of which is a way to get
high to get fidelity on given hardware
and then put two things together because
you will see that this is actually based
on very similar techniques than the
implementation of cue AOA and think
about what could be a good way to
actually program a variation or quantum
algorithm on a suitable piece of
hardware
so why Co design well we are calling
where we are now the era of misc and I
think one feature that everybody sees
even people coming from the world of
application and computer science is that
when you even use the best platforms
that are available you do see properties
a concentrate of the hardware when you
implementing things to do error
avoidance and there's sometimes the
qubit not working in that connectivity
so I am I kind of favorite analogy here
the picture of my first computer I have
alone the one on the left person on the
right is the brains behind the company
Sinclair research for the genius of
British engineering and with those
computers which had one kilobyte of RAM
my 13 year old self discovered after a
very short time of owning its that I can
really do more if a neural assembler and
I learned a lot of say how the ROM was
done and I think so I very early learned
how to program following architecture
and I think you know this
what we should still cherish in this era
to really get kind of the best impact
out of what the hardware research which
on the one hand is progressing enormous
ly but on the other hand still has a
long way to go
can currently offer and one connection
that it kind of easy to see how these
things are connected is two qubit gates
versus physical interactions
following the truism that if we want to
make a two qubit gate which now easily
where we say okay we make a gate by
exponentiating a Hamiltonian for a
certain time more practically we're
using a cleverly designed time-dependent
Hamiltonian and we're solving the two
qubits there's a time dependent
Schrodinger equation but on both of the
time evolution operators on the right
sorry I don't have a mouse pointer so I
will talk here this number doesn't seem
to work on my computer I will talk to
you to where I would like to you to look
so clearly if I with these expressions
for you gate want to make it two qubit
gate I need a term in the Hamiltonian
it's non-trivial in both cubed so I need
a physical interaction as stroll in the
Hamiltonian sketch on the upper right
which is kind of grouping singer in two
cubed terms and in a one of the early
papers discussing apart the quantum
supremacy this was kind of put rigidly
very succinctly this was a first version
of the random circuit leading to a
positive mass distribution from Google
where you obviously see that they took
qubit gates or between neighboring
qubits because this was meant to be
compiled on the chain so the interaction
was nearest neighbor on a chain and it
was shown that this is actually enough
but then as we know and they're sifting
this conference till a different
solution was chosen for good reasons and
another case of co.design that we can
look at is quantum annealing
so I think this was introduced to many
times before and probably wouldn't have
deep interaction anyway but let me just
point you what I want you to see on the
left a quantum annealing anyway
has a very similar simple way of
controlling the system with typically
one global field only which is encoded
in this function a of F that is slowly
blending us from the driver Hamiltonian
HD at time zero at the bottom of the
left column you see the requirement of
the annealing schedule to the problem
Hamiltonian on the right where the
solution the problem that we want to
solve is encoded it's this diagram the
basis the driver is X and the X basis so
we need much simpler controls and in
adiabatic quantum computing the kind of
close cousin or Chris or the subset of
quantum annealing we even have to
constrain that we varied it Mary slowly
and certainly this has evolved a bit but
let's just look at what this does to
chips so I'm showing pictures of gate
model hardware I think it's my qubit
ship from John's group it's still
extremely popular because there still
everything open and it's beautiful
picture of course the modern things I
capsulated for good reasons don't worry
about that but even if you are you know
there's probably a more experimentally
oriented crawl today also but even if
you look at this and not knowing a lot
about hardware you see that there is a
high frequency wiring there are these
separated wires they are the little big
you oscillate at the top of the cross
which are all needed because this thing
is operated under a fast clock with
microwaves and if you look at a typical
cryostat insert you know the steampunky
logo of modern quantum computing on the
right this is something from our open
super few project you see that there is
this gigantic wiring assembly which is
needed to get high frequency signals in
a knot on the bottom figures you see
pictures of the d-wave chips which Gaza
encapsulated much earlier and which are
aiming at implementing the quantum
annealing paradigm so one thing you see
in the middle figure is there this
golden long qubit not the localized
crosses
which intersect the coupling points
because in quantum annealing a lot of
the coding is done in physical
interaction the problem Hamiltonian
needs to encode a complicated coupling
problem which you can avoid by using
swap gates and gate model you see on the
left but this is kind of not a very
clearly you know it's not quite so clear
to see what's going on because of the
type of picture you see that next to the
long stretch lines of qubits there are
these little rectangular coils on top
and there's a lot of other elements put
right on ships which are used to pre
program the super contra serve each do
not need to be kept away because the
coherence requirements are different and
also on the right you see that this by
ring assembly is not as elaborate as for
the gauge model quantum computer you can
go with much more simpler wires that
only carry low frequencies because you
do not need this high frequency
precision so if you want quantum
annealing is an extreme core design of a
quantum computer that it's meant to
implement these type of quantum
algorithms and now of course the big
thing in the mascara which we've heard a
lot about yesterday our variational
algorithms where like in a very a in a
hybrid bike for example we use the
scarce resource which in the hybrid by
caste and the content of the battery
which and which for quantum computer is
the quantum computer coherence for the
things that axes need to be done there
and you're integrating is the successor
charisma which is much cheaper that
sends new parameters to quantum
algorithm as shown in the upper panel
and of course on the bottom there is a
sketch of the qaa or algorithm where
essentially the pre factors of the
problem and driver Hamiltonian are also
determined by a classical algorithm and
this is a prime candidate for quantum
simulation and we can ask if we want to
implement these things are there also
suitable for designs that goes to one
example from a group it's a bit older
but I think it's worth repeating which
is to go from molecules to materials we
have seen in Chris Monroe's talk
when you want to simulate a molecule but
you really simulated the curve like on
the upper left that specifically look at
the bottom curve this is the energy of a
molecular bond in this case in lithium
hydride as a function of distance of the
two nuclei and finding the minimum gives
you the bond length and the depth of the
minimum gives you the binding energy the
energy that holds the molecule together
and if you the moonshot of this
community is to simulate the molecule on
the bottom actually to simulate the core
this is ferredoxin to iron two sulfur
explains an important role potent role
in photosynthesis which we humans would
like to imitate now the variational a
self energy method is aiming at solid
state materials like for example high
temperature superconductor and even
though we learn that in quantum
computing if we have in a molecule if we
have n orbitals we only need a police
number of qubits that polynomial the
number of orbitals we wouldn't want to
do this here because for solid state
materials the number of constituents is
controlled by Avogadro's number six
times 10 to the 23 and even a polynomial
this is primitive but as we learned from
henderson pictures here and who recently
passed away going from a molecule to a
material really changes how you should
look at this actually just to appreciate
Phil Anderson in this community you know
he's when I I'm really fraying at the
corners metal physicist and he's like a
towering figure of this and I think it's
fair to say that he invented the
statement that things like the Hubbard
model described Connors metaphysics
before the era of skill Anderson when
you did college metaphysics or the state
physics you needed to describe a
concrete material and not a model system
that describes a lot of other systems so
in this system the energy doesn't have
an
legs doesn't tell us as much as it does
in the molecule and we have looked at
specifically if the hogwarts model which
is a model of a very rich face diagram
which is believed to model some aspects
of the physics of high-temperature
superconductors so what you want to get
is the phase diagram on the right you
want to see where is this anti
ferromagnetic where is this
superconducting where does it have all
other phases it's a complicated model
but it has been well studied so this is
a valid way to try out how to simulate a
material on a quantum computer without
needing 10 to the 23 cubits and what we
want is we do not want to really compute
the energy we want to compute something
like the greens function so the greens
function shown on top is an interesting
object in many-body theory and you need
to read this expression in the angular
bracket kind of from right to left
because this is how time goes side Eggar
means you take them anybody system and
you're putting in an electron at
position R Prime at time T Prime sy
means you're taking it out at position R
and time T and then there are some time
ordering going on so this really tells
you what as a single electron do in the
many-body background and it helps you to
for example find out in which phase you
are now in superconductivity this is
actually a matrix and they're using
spinners but the really interesting
thing is that we are now essentially
looking at the energy not of a single
particle but at the energy and the
physics of a particle moving in our
solid state system and in fact there's
an object called the self energy sold by
define Mint diagrams in the middle of
the left column where a electron
essentially has an energy contribution
is coming from everything around it and
you're summing up the interaction with
the environment repeatedly and you get
there Fineman are this Feynman diagram
expression and the interesting thing is
that this self energy is generalized
energy if you want now also satisfies a
variational principle in that the
thermodynamic potential Omega the grand
potential with respect to the self
energy satisfies a variation a saddle
point condition this is called the
variational classical methods and true
now keep them so you now can use an
answer for yourself energy the same way
as you use an untouched for your
molecule and try to find a solution for
this expression with the UH thoughts now
the answers you're using is you're
taking your lattice you're dropping it
into little pizzas thrown in H prime
that you're solving exactly and then
you're using an approximate method that
is sketched on the bottom to build the
whole lettuce out of these little
clusters and the method gets more and
more precise if if classes get bigger
and the idea of our algorithm was now to
take the solution of the cluster that he
needs to be exact on to a quantum
computer and then do the variation
equation classically and this is the
co.design it is leading to if we go back
to the greens function if you break down
the greens function into a few bits this
is essentially an out-of-time
correlation functions or you have you
digitize in a sigma sorry decide in two
cubed you measure it at different times
you measure this correlator for which
it's sufficient to have a single probe
qubit with measurements connected to one
chain of qubits that contains the state
of the hub off model you can efficiently
deal with this wrapping overhead there
and you need a second chain that you use
for simulating finite temperature and
what is interesting is that no buyers
cross in this architecture and making
vias cross in the superconducting chip
is a big challenge it's as we have seen
by Google now a salt problem but it's
still very inconvenient and on the right
we show that if you look at the second
line from the bottom that with 54 sorry
55 qubits you could already use do these
clusters of three by three by three and
that would outperform classical
computers so here kind of a long
preloads there is a co.design now let's
look at the second
1q AOA with only single cubed controls
preprint we have on this is actually
called approximating the quantum
approximate optimization algorithm so
the Q AOA was introduced yesterday it
consists of taking the driver and the
problem Hamiltonian that I've shown with
quantum annealing and applying it in an
alternating fashion and then use the
classical optimizer to find optimal
times for which you apply these
algorithms until your readout in the end
if you're satisfactory solution so it's
a variation algorithm for combinatorial
optimization problems and it requires
that the driver and the Hamilton problem
Hamiltonian can be switched to implement
the gate sequence so and it's photo
right adiabatic so this is too
complicated we want to make it simpler
so the first thing is that we realize
that it is we try what happens if we are
actually never switching of the problem
Hamiltonian we let it run all the time
and we simply and we want to implement
the algorithm so first of all
implementing the problem Hamiltonian
which for reasons that will become clear
in a minute because the resource
interaction that's well actually the
time to implement it will simply be
given by the waiting times between the
singing qubit gates now the single qubit
gates that we are running while the
interaction is switched on will not have
the same effect there will be an error
by the simultaneous presence of both
hamiltonians
to control its error we introduce a
speed ratio alpha being the Rabi
frequency over the interaction strength
so the Rabi frequency is the strength of
a single qubit drive and so the
interaction strength is the size of the
problem Hamiltonian and if you estimate
the error it scales as alpha squared
times N squared where n is the number of
qubits
it turns out that it is too pessimistic
we have done simulations
random instances of queue AOA and
because this color-coded picture it has
a bit of structure in it which means we
should have take even more instances but
what you can see is that at a speed
ratio of about a hundred it turns
brownish which means that our simpler QA
Oh a hardware efficient queue AOA is
actually slightly better than the
regular QA away whereas on the left it
gets a bit worse by up to ten percent so
even if we are on the Left if we are ten
to the one we get you know a decrease of
about four percent which may even still
be acceptable but in some cases we even
get improvement so why is this soul why
did we did our little estimate was so
badly well because of the urea question
we are asking here the red question we
are asking queue AOA is to go from a
well-defined initial stage everything in
Sigma X to a target state that gives you
a good approximation of your
optimization problem and for this you're
dialing in your parameters beta and
gamma even if during the application on
the drive on the middle panel of our
simplified queue AOA of our approximate
queue AOA is slightly wrong the
optimizer the classical optimizer can
partially compensate this by choosing
the right value different values of the
angle you do not want to implement the Q
AOA exactly you just want to make sure
that your structure is rich enough so
you can reach the target space and if
you need to express it slightly
differently if you get slightly
different parameters
this is totally acceptable it's not that
you have an algorithm where you need to
precisely follow a recipe so this is
quite unique to variational algorithm
that it's so tolerant for the simplified
implementation we could go even further
we could so what we could do now is
essentially use D waves idea to preset
the interactions on the trip and not
touch them
during the computation that greatly
reducing the number of high-frequency
lines that need to go because you do not
need to pass couplers anymore you can
slowly programmer and another thing you
could do is if you were able and in some
platforms that may be possible I think
Richburg is a good candidate to
essentially make a constant all-to-all
interaction shown here as a resource
Hamiltonian you can use fast single
qubit X k2 there's a typo in this
formula the first XK should be in Excel
to essentially conjugate this
Hamiltonian around the x-axis and by
carefully choosing the time the [ __ ]
who applies several pairs of SKT LM you
always need to switch on to single qubit
X gates you can actually cuts down the
resource Hamiltonian through your
problem Hamiltonian so from your
interactions our JK you need to go
through your wanted to your problem
Hamiltonian djk for this you need to
find the application time PLM and in the
paper we show that this is a simple
matrix inversion problem that is
solvable and of course number of qubits
squares so this way you can actually
avoid controlling your two qubit
interactions altogether as long as you
have them and again this may have
hopefully inspire new Co designs so here
are two cases where we can make hard we
are simpler if we decide that it's
variation algorithms what we like to go
through also we have shown that we can
compile this efficiently here is an
example of compiling the algorithm
properly and given that you're running
the interaction and the single cubic
eight simultaneously it even gets a bit
shorter because you need to be working
in cubed arrows but that's a bit of an
aside so now for something completely
different ad so it's seen it's not
something that happens in a different
office in my groups namely lower error
rates with optimal control so here is
kind of the optimal control gospel that
we have been talking about for the last
15 years
if you have a Hamiltonian with some
uncontrolled term h0 and some controls
field UI and some control hamiltonians
HJ these can be your microwave drives
and things like this and if you want to
force the time evolution to make a gates
by the solution U of T F at the final
time of your time dependent Schrodinger
equation you can use numerical
variational calculus to adjust your path
shape so if that's what you want under
optimal conditions now the problem if
this field you can see on the right this
is from work we've actually done from
drawn withdrawn in the project together
we've drawn in the pre-google area
around the tread this is a very fast way
to do a qubit gates or a resonator and
what you see is that the pulse shape is
quite complicated so if it's right if it
worked it's good but if it doesn't work
it is very difficult to debug because if
you understand your arrow you don't
quite know how to change the pulse shape
to accommodate for this now in the past
and I'm telling this because I will show
an example how to improve this there was
a successful optimization of quantum
optimal control it has to do with
leakage reduction in the popular trends
mom if you see on the left we have this
ladder of energy levels and the detuning
of the 0 to 1 transition relative who
they want to to transition that the
number hotels are 2 is not really big so
if you're driving a system fast like
shown in the middle the spectrum of your
driving pulse on the 0 1 transition may
actually overlap with the one to
transition and drive it also but we
showed that by applying a drive where
you're shaping the cosine Omega T of
your eternal drive at the find Omega T
at the same time and where the envelopes
follow this little differential
equations or what is the derivative the
other you can reduce this by a lot and
it's for me kind of point of pride that
this PR al is now in most experimental
control software check box you say you
want to track and it's doing track now
this worked really well because it has
few parameters so the software that is
running at modeling experiments could
very easily implement this because up
with the simple parametrization of this
optimal control you can calibrate
everything of the experiment it will hit
you again everywhere and then do an
experiment so why would you do not do
this a fully optimized pulses well
because they are complicated and because
applying a complicated pulse requires
that your Hamiltonian on the right is
known precisely that there is absolutely
no uncontrolled degrees of freedom here
also called drunk that the whole
filtering setup that goes from room
temperature to the chip is completely
characterized and stable which to the
precision needed is very difficult to do
that some of the energy levels thrown on
the right in the round box are actually
really really hard to pinpoint
completely which is why applying a
non-intuitive pulse like the one on the
left is usually impossible because of
all these uncertainties now I should say
that specifically world in the world of
cash qubits actually people do apply
these optimal control causes efficiently
in this case the system is very well
characterized and the pulses operate on
a relatively narrow bandwidth for which
they experimentalists are able to find a
good model but now we want to be as fast
as possible and use larger bandwidth so
we have to do something else and here is
a recent result of preprint of this
March that has actually worked so what
you see in the upper left is the typical
drag strategy you see the red line is
the envelope of your pulse the blue line
is its time derivative this is what you
use a usual track and now we have used
numerical optimization with 55
parameters to actually push this curve a
lot further what you see in the lower
left is deposit that are coming out
which are really quite far deformed from
the law from the upper left but you also
see the randomised benchmarking results
panel C and D
that show that with the piecewise
constant parameterization has been used
here we get a lot less error
specifically at Short times compared to
the simple drag and this is also sampled
on the right at some points you see on
the right the fidelity is going down
because track is running into its limit
whereas our solution saturate
essentially until the drive power is so
high that there is strong nonlinear
responses of the equipment and this is
like parameter at IBM in Switzerland now
the reason why I'm making this interlude
is that I want to share a little bit
with you the long period of resource
that went into it
specifically if you look at the loop on
the Left we have essentially follow the
workflow where the experimentalist first
design your system they characterize it
we numerically give them a couple of
pulses by au normal optimal control
methods and then by measuring fidelity
with randomized benchmarking and in situ
pulse updates we are calibrating the
experiment without having a model this
requires that your pulse is simple and
we have found a gradient based optimized
are shown on the left that does only
give you a piecewise constant pulses but
that is directly allows you to optimize
Fourier components because typically a
Fourier component ation with a gentle
envelope like the one shown in the
middle is the most efficient and the
most sparse and parameter economical way
to describe how to drive a quantum
system it's not timeslice tapes
typically we address it we are getting
towards these AC solutions and on the
right is something we are coming up with
which is essentially using a method from
artificial intelligence to improve the
closed-loop part of the diagram on the
left and to also see what does the
calibration actually teach us about the
model can we from the calibration data
learn more about the system that we need
so this is if you want AI enhanced
spectral
capisce now this had to go in there I
won't go through the details because
that would be a whole different talk but
what you can appreciate is that the
lower part of the Left diagram is very
similar to setting up a variational
quantum algorithm we are trying
something we measure our success and
then we update the way how we try based
on our success and what you also see on
the right is that we have a way to deal
with non optimality of the
implementation that I have shown in the
QA way application where we're not quite
implementing QA the correct way but we
can compensate for this by choosing our
puzzles a bit different so if you want
if you want to make an extreme statement
Q AOA is a difficult I'm discretized a
bang-bang version of pulse update and
it's an algorithm version of an
algorithm level of updates so it's on a
whole processor and whole algorithm not
on a single gate thanks 10 10 minute
time check ok I'll be done in three
minutes so this I would like to put this
observation in a bit of a more of an
extreme way and suggest the following if
we look at Q AOA on a very superficial
way above we are having a couple of
gates and we're choosing variational
parameters to switch on operations
rapidly in time to apply rapid single
qubit gates and statements about
variational algorithms being or
Universal have to typically have to do
with having enough parameters to reach
every potential output state that we
would like to do so this is essentially
statement about controllability are the
resources that I have generally enough
so I can do everything I want
now the way how I propose to look at
puree bringing in tools from optimal
control is shown in the bottom where
essentially we are not slicing up the
application of driver all of the parts
that we need to actually reach a
universality and programmability not
time discrete but in a way that is as
efficient as possible that can be
parameters of sine and cosine waves and
again what we need is essentially a
guarantee that our setting is rich
enough to do what we like it to do you
get a final state that offers us a good
solution of the problem we're interested
in so there is again a statement about
controllability and probably also
constraints and this is in control see
you reach our goal is called the
reachable set and I feel that for if we
have hardware that is general enough the
bottom approach can help us to get
higher performance when we get closer to
some type of true disruption so this is
kind of not even a summary this is also
trying to segue into a discussion is
that these I think that the software on
and for quantum computers so by software
on quantum computers I mean algorithms
that we would like to implement and
software for quantum computers I mean
the stack below it including the optimal
control tools that I've shown you to
calibrate games those need to be closely
integrated also for things like low
latency in order to implement the
algorithms and in a good way and I think
this is a software part of code design
that goes with the hardware part of core
design which I try to convince you is
trying to leave things that are things
out that are unnecessary for the
application I have in mind with the goal
that I will not I don't have to build
them and I can scale more aggressively I
became an even take this further and
ponder the thought enable II that Agia
basic quantum computer
ting gate model and this quantum control
approach are probably three initial
programming paradigms motivated by
physics for the adiabatic theorem
computer science because this is how we
like to think about computers and
chemistry which is where quantum control
was mostly pioneered and I would like to
advocate for exploring the spaces in
between and to look at much more hybrid
programming solutions because ultimately
these approaches as much as they can be
proven to be very powerful in order to
be practical
they probably you know they're coming
from a tradition and probably the most
efficient way to program a limited
quantum computer is the hybrid of the
three and bishops - that was a
pretentious ending thank you very much
for your attention
ok thank you Frank
so we are open for discussion I I have
in my own list I have actually just a
rather technical question but let me
pose it to you in the early part of your
talk you introduced a variational
principle concerning the grand potential
which is interesting could you explain
why or is this a simple understanding of
why it's a saddle point extremum problem
rather than a minimum I do not have a
really simple explanation for that no
this is coming out of a long calculation
and nothing less explanation sorry but
it is a fact that it's not a minimum
it's really a saddle point it's
typically a No
so we say saddle point metaphorically as
an extremum ok as a point that satisfies
this equation so yes mm-hmm
ok ok and so I should also say this
method or classical computers were not
invented by us the big name throughout
this or which Airport sauce and double
seneschal is the letter I think being
actually a chef or colleague of our
previous speaker
okay so any further comments or
discussion of this contribution there's
a there's something in the chat which I
find totally incomprehensible sorry Q&A
I mean luckily it's still mr. anonymous
or miss anonymous what quantum laptop
commercial oh well maybe I missed
something but does anyone know what that
means
I guess not
okay they're asking whether or not we
will have commercial quantum laptops and
I think I can answer that on Frank's
behalf and say it will be a very long
time mm okay
I would even augment that the most
powerful use computers most people use
in their daily life are the ones that
navigates them around the city traffic
and they are not owning them they're
accessing them to the CRU the cloud and
I would argue that this is probably also
the right place for the quantum
algorithms we currently know about so if
it's a long time and I'm not worried
about this in the post PC world we are
moving computing power to somebody
else's computer which is the honest
version of saying the cloud and that is
not a so I think the quantum laptop is
also not really a goal I'm just gonna
summarize what Frank just said and asked
why do you want a quantum laptop I think
what you really want is a quantum
computer that works yeah so are there
are there more questions about the talk
just given Frank so this code design
sounds nice but so like it's a theorist
you say well you know if I had this
connectivity that you're sharing there
on the current slide there would be
great but then you know the current labs
that are making qubits they don't
provide that so how do we go about that
yeah I mean the idea is that these Co
designs are trying to remove elements
that are hard to make for current labs
and you know we can argue the d-wave is
an extreme case as they are putting a
lot of units on the chip because they do
not need to lose that much for them now
to go about this so first of all people
could make it their mission of building
the perfect through AOA machine QA o is
principle universal and see whether they
can really scale more aggressively if we
will also think about if we're looking
at Co designs that still require
microwave drives is to build an
experimental set up that is standardized
that has a couple of low frequency lines
that has a couple of high frequency
lines that has a microwave tight box and
that has a very well-defined interface
so the whole set of the cryostat the
wiring are always the same and then
allow to connect different chips to it
but at the moment I would say it's
mostly if somebody wants to build a
hobbit model solver or a QA Oh a machine
they could basically make bit faster
progress by studying these ideas a lot
of the other things actually would not
change it is also probably it could
encourage people to think about hardware
that otherwise was difficult to use and
to think about elements that could be
used for always-on interactions or for
example connect a lot of flux qubits to
one common group that connects them all
to all and use single qubit gates to
remove them and by this way again make
more make progress scale faster
okay so I think we come to the end now
of the seminar the presentations of this
evening and in the whole week so we have
just a wrap-up and a panel discussion
and let me begin a little bit with the
with the panel discussion through the
remote age and I'd like to thank
actually I actually had been on but I
think she's off again but like to have
thank all the staff that worked hard and
of course omid for keeping us our
computers all in order as we come to the
end of the week here
so I think well let me actually ask the
organization are we going to just record
straight through or are you going to
take a break or you will that you indeed
record the final panel as a as a
discrete event are you asking me David
say say that again yeah are you asking
me I am yes yes so yeah my plan was to
start recording and then started again
at the panel okay so I think you can
stop now and then within a few minutes
we'll be ready to launch the panel